welcome to 8701
so in this lecture we'll give you the
first introduction to final diagram
this is part one out of a few sections
on fundamental fernandez so this is
really meant to introduce the topic
such that we can use the same language
to talk about feminine diagram before we
then
later on are able to use them as a tool
to calculate
interesting processes
this brings me right um to the essence
already
what is a feminine diagram and what can
it be used for um
they arise from uh perturbative
calculations of
amplitude for reactions and that's
exactly how we're going to use them
later on it turns out that
the mathematical terms in the
perturbation theory
can be represented as a diagram
and then you can turn this around and
use the diagram in order to perform a
calculation
so each of the diagram then indicates a
particular
factor in the calculation again and then
you have a rule
which allows you to you know after
drawing you can then
put the pieces together in order to
perform the full calculation
um the derivation of those tools or
rules
is beyond the content of this course but
i will teach you
how to actually use diagrams to
calculate things
so here's one example of a diagram let
me just put this down here so you can
see this
um this is an electron
uh radiating a photon okay um
you see components like those lines here
those represent particles with energy
and momentum
i also want to consider the spin um and
the meat at a point
this point here is called a vertex
and this is where the interaction takes
place and in this example
you know the the vertex is labeled with
the q or e
representing the charge the electric
charge which
gives us the strength of the coupling we
already discussed when we talked about
units that we can
express the strength of the
electromagnetic the coupling in qed
with the electric charge and that's
shown below again
um the amplitude then turns out to be
proportional to the charge or to this
coupling and the diagrams with n
vertices
so n of those components here
um get the factor e
the charge to the nth power in the
amplitude and e to the second because
if you're going to calculate the
probability you have to square the
amplitude you get a factor of e to
2n again don't get confused e is
charge um so for n vertices there will
be a factor
alpha with the nth power for the
probability
and so since alpha is one over 137
um you see that if i want to do
calculation
um and you know diagrams which have
n vertices will be suppressed uh will
not contribute much to our perturbation
series because
alpha is much much smaller than one so
this is already an interesting finding
you can restrict yourself to calculating
diagrams which have a couple of vertices
or n vertices
but you don't have to calculate the
entire series if you want to measure
calculation with experimental findings
uh interesting here anti-particles um
if you have a specific vertex and you
calculate it
it can be reused it can be reused for
example by
replacing a particle with an
anti-particle um
or you know by we we will be labeling
one thing i haven't explained to you yet
you have to define when you write them
which is the direction of time
for example this direction here so in
this case here
um you have an particle and an
anti-particle
unrelating to a photon
um so far so good so me
this is again a good
point to stop and just try to to read
the diagrams
note that you know what happens in this
discussion when you actually change the
direction of time
for down if you want either directions
so now if we want to calculate a
reaction it's not sufficient to just use
one vertex
why because a single vertex will not be
able to give us a reaction you can
simply see this when you look at
something like an electron plus electron
photon
um this is not really possible because
of energy and momentum conservation in
this diagram so you need a couple of
vertices in order to make
a reaction so this here is again
we have potentially the time going this
direction is a scattering between an
electron
and a muon through the exchange of a
proton both particles have electric
charge of e
and they have you know then you can just
calculate what is the
probability for a process like this to
occur you'll see how to do this
technically later on
but hopefully you have a first
impression again just label this now
very quickly we have an incoming
particle a second incoming particle
outgoing particles and
an exchange particle so this exchange
particle is a photon
and that's two vertices in this diagram
you